negotiators have reached a draft deal on
a climate compensation fund at the un's
cop 27 Summit in Egypt after days of
gridlock the new draft proposal would
sea countries agree to set up a fund to
compensate the vulnerable Nations
bearing the brunt of climate change
calls for such a fund have dominated the
last two weeks of talks but the proposal
still needs to be voted on by delegates
and postpones the key decision of which
countries would pay into the new fund
until the next year's U.N climate Summit
I'm joined Now by our correspondent Sam
Baker in shomal Sheikh Sam we're hearing
that a deal might have been reached on
loss and damaged what more can you tell
us
yes that appears to be the case multiple
countries are signaling their support
for this deal and so far I haven't heard
any speaking out against it so this is a
fund that would be established to pay
for loss and damage and that is money
that will go towards countries that need
it after climate disasters so climate
vulnerable poorer countries that need
that money many of them are signaling
their support saying this fund offers
hope but the details will need to be
worked out for next year and the most
important one will be where the money is
going to come from so the the sources of
money for that fund
from the outside looking in it it seemed
that delegates were at an impasse so
this is a major development what remains
to be agreed on
the main thing that still needs to be
agreed on is mitigation so that's one of
those buzzwords here at cop27 but
basically what it means is reducing
emissions so the language in the draft
text right now
is almost identical to what we had last
year in Glasgow and that doesn't reduce
emissions to keep warming to 1.5 degrees
or less than that
and you know the warming of two degrees
would be quite different than 1.5
degrees we would lose coral reefs 60
million more people would have to deal
with droughts that would lead to hunger
and searching for water 12 million more
people would deal with coastal flooding
so as it stands right now they're just
holding those emissions reductions to
work towards two degrees that was agreed
in the Paris agreement
so big picture perspective here what's
essentially at stake
it's going to be at the end of the
century so we're looking at a half a
degrees difference
um and like I said that's going to
affect people on coastlines dealing with
drought dealing with worse heat waves
um so this this is the element that
still has to be decided on
so DW Sam Baker in shamoshik many thanks
Sam
and our colleagues in shamosha caught up
with climate activists amiteshwa Singh
they asked him about his perspective on
cop 27.
I'm disappointed
I'm saddened
I'm hurt and I'm not just heard from
myself I'm hurt for the people that are
being affected right now I'm hurt for
the people that I've talked to that have
cried to me that have pleaded for help
although they know that I cannot provide
them that they're pleading because they
don't have access to anybody in the
global North to actually lead to that
half decision-making Powers so I am here
to send that message to the people that
have that power I am here to remind them
that people are hurt
people have been affected and their
decisions right now and throughout these
whole two weeks is what is affecting us
I made a reminder that they're here to
work and the need to get to work quickly
and now there needs to be no comparison
between one thing and another it needs
to be Collective it needs to come
together and we can win only that way
the effects of climate change are all
too apparent in Somalia we're a
humanitarian catastrophe is unfolding
the worst drought in 40 years has left
Millions on the brink of starvation the
United Nations says half a million
children under five could die the
government has not officially declared a
famine which would unlock more financial
aid our correspondent Mario Muller
traveled to baidoa at the center of the
hunger crisis this next report contains
images some viewers might find upsetting
I am
these children are fighting for their
lives
from all over Somalia those most in need
get referred to this Hospital in the
capital Mogadishu
many die on the way
little Amina Abdi weighs less than half
of what a healthy child her age should
for days she's been in a coma I'm in
Abdi now she she's
uh unusually normally she was supposed
to be 16 kg she came with severeign
nutrition with critical condition we
just call it shock now she is a terminal
case
a terminal case at only four years old
this is the impact of the extreme
drought that's devastating Somalia it's
the worst in 40 years
baidua is 250 kilometers west of the
capital it is seen as the epicenter of
The Hunger crisis
the situation in the hospital here is
desperate
according to the UN a child is being
admitted for medical treatment every
minute famine hasn't been officially
declared yet by the government but a
doctor told me based on the cases
they're seeing the situation now is even
worse than during the last femin 2011
when a quarter of a million people died
one and a half year old Mariam was
admitted a few days ago she's showing
typical symptoms of malnutrition
diarrhea vomiting and whooping cough
foreign
for her mother and Aunt the weight is
unbearable
I feel so sad for my sister
I pray to Allah that she will recover
and also that he will alleviate the
drought
like most somalis both were livestock
Farmers until the drought took
everything from them
four rainy seasons have failed and they
are fears that a fifth will Now fail too
High food prices due to the war in
Ukraine decades-long Civil War and
climate change have created an
unprecedented humanitarian disaster Aid
organizations warn millions are on the
brink of starvation
the United Nations Children's Fund
UNICEF says 1 billion US dollars in Aid
is needed to avoid the situation getting
worse we have half a million children
that are severely acutely malnourish
which basically means that if don't if
they don't receive assistance timely
they are just simply going to die 800
000 people have sowed refuge in and
around by door they've doubled the
City's population
mayor Abdullahi watin says he needs
long-term solutions to deal with the
crisis Somalia is one of the affected
areas in in by the climate change but
what will happen after the truth and
this do we wait
until another farming comes or we we
still come up with with initiatives that
we need to mitigate a future shocks he
expects help from the world's biggest
polluters
while African countries contribute less
than three percent to climate change
they are among the most vulnerable to
its impact